it's a daily struggle giving his every
effort to get back on his feet
it's been eight months since Alexander
sustained a cervical spine injury in an
airstrike in the southern region of her
son
it happened on Ukraine's Independence
Day
I was at a military hospital to check my
eyes when he came under attack with
cluster bombs three pieces of sharpener
flew into my back it is hard when I came
here I could only move my toes to do
that I needed to push myself so hard now
I'm trying to walk with crutches
an Untold number of Ukrainian soldiers
have been seriously wounded in combat
loss of limb is one of the main injuries
also among civilians the exact numbers
classified by the ministry of Defense
but one estimate says it's happened to
over ten thousand ukrainians mostly
soldiers
at the Without Limits Rehabilitation
Center in Kiev therapists say demand for
Prosthetics is very high
creating a mold is the first step into
making a prosthetic and then the patient
will have to go through rehabilitation
but psychologists say that mental health
needs to be given equal attention
veteran Hub provides support for active
soldiers through a network of mental
health workers like our tem who also
fought in the Eastern dumbass region I
was shocked I was working with these
guys and after a year I become this guy
you know and I was so surprised how easy
it could be I forget about my life I
forget I forgot that I am Psychotherapy
psychotherapist for a year and then I
came back because I had this opportunity
and I was like wow
what a
what a mess
Roman College Nick has put his career as
a professional athlete on post when he
enrolled in the as of Battalion he lost
part of his right leg but is glad that
he survived he is now fighting the urge
to return to the combat zone
I think about it every day but after I
saw what my relatives went through I
can't I can't give them more pain it was
harder for them than it was for me
I will make my dreams come true I want
to become world champion in mixed
martial arts and I'm going for it
about 70 percent of soldiers return to
active service after treatment once the
hostilities end Ukraine will have to
deal with the long-term impact of War on
the visible and invisible injuries on
its people